our syringe filters come with pore sizes  ranging from 0.2 micrometers to 0.45  micrometers with the diameters ranging  from 13 millimeters to 33 millimeters  the membranes we currently offer are  nylon CA PES PTFE hptfe pvdf glass fiber  MCE and PP the DX line of filters are a  standard filtration product and works  for the vast majority of applications  the RT line of filters has the same  membranes as the DX line however they  offer color-coded Rings the gfb line of  filters has a glass fiber pre-filter and  lastly the svx the svx line of filters  has a multi-mode pre-filter system and  is used for the most difficult to filter  samples the svx product can even filter  out ketchup